e o menino do pobre ele pede só que ele
não diz assim ei me dá ele fica
descrevendo o que a pessoa tá comendo
até ela dar um pedaço para ele tava
comendo uma coxinha e o caba fica assim
ó tu é doido mas isso aí é bom né caba
assa assim na gordura bem gostosinho Tu
é doido caba desse jeito aí de
manhazinha bem quentinho Tu é doido de
frango aí o cara bota o o o o catchup
doido tu bota o catchup aí doido tu é
doido o cara bota fica bem gostosinho
não o cara bota na boca R der tem quando
R derretendo tem quando R derretendo bem
mesmo no não tem Tu é doido mas você é
bom demais amor eu lembro o dia que eu
comi isso aí na casa de um primo meu
cava é meu primo mãe dele faz coxinha
mas tu é doido mordendo do jeito que tu
tá mordendo aí tu é doido tem não mas
você é gostoso demais vontade de comer o
nesse não sei o que eu faço ó cara quer
um pedaço p não queria não mas vou comer
né Aí come eu fiz isso aí demais meu
patrão